Naomi und Ruby van Dijk lernen wieder,
das Turnen zu lieben.
Viele Jahre lang war ihre Liebe
zu diesem Sport verschwunden.
Im Alter von zehn Jahren – bereit für
große Erfolge – zogen die Zwillinge
in ein Elitetrainingszentrum
in der Nähe von Köln.
Doch als ihre Leistungen nachließen,
wurden sie von ihrem Trainer
als fett und faul beschimpft.
Das Schlimmste fand ich eigentlich,
dass er dann teilweise auch
bei Wettkämpfen gesagt hat:
„Nein, ich fahre nicht mit,
weil ihr blamiert mich.“
Und das ist eben … Wenn man 14 Jahre alt
ist oder 15, braucht man, finde ich,
einen Trainer, der eben hinter einem steht,
egal wie schlecht man turnt.
Bei jedem Wettkampf, wo wir
dann hingefahren sind …
Um dann entweder kurz
vor dem Wettkampf zu sagen:
„Na ja, ihr seid zu schwer.“
Oder: „Ihr blamiert mich.“
Bei einer Barrenübung wurde Naomi
nach eigenen Angaben absichtlich
auf den Kopf fallen gelassen,
um ihr eine Lektion zu erteilen.
Der hat mich vorher halt zwei-,
dreimal aufgefordert,
ich soll tiefer runtergehen, tiefer runtergehen.
Aber ich wusste ja, dass er mich eh nicht hält.
Deswegen bin ich nicht tiefer runtergegangen.
Und dann hat er es halt …
Beim dritten Mal bin ich tiefer
runtergegangen, da hat er losgelassen.
Und dann war es so nach dem Motto:
„Ja, siehst du?“
Sie beschwerten sich beim
regionalen Turnverband.
Dort habe man sie nicht ernst
genommen oder ihnen nicht geglaubt
und ihnen das Gefühl gegeben,
sie seien das Problem.
Also, ich weiß noch,
dass ich mit 14 dann auch einfach keinen
Turnanzug mehr anziehen wollte.
Und habe immer halt gedacht,
das ist ja … Alles an mir ist falsch:
also mein Aussehen, wo ich herkomme,
wie ich turne, wie ich rede, wie ich bin.
Also, das hat einfach so meine
Persönlichkeit schon verletzt.
Der Rheinische Turnerbund zeigte sich
in einer Stellungnahme – Zitat – „überrascht“
von den Vorwürfen und ergänzt:
„Der RTB nimmt die
erhobenen Vorwürfe sehr ernst
und wird die Sachverhalte
schnellstmöglich aufklären.“
Damals wurde Ruby und
Naomi van Dijk gesagt,
sie sollten sich entweder
mit dem Trainer abfinden,
den Sport aufgeben oder
– was sie schließlich taten –
in das Elitetrainingszentrum
nach Chemnitz wechseln.
Vor einigen Wochen wurden Probleme dort
vom Magazin „Der Spiegel“ aufgedeckt.
Mehr als ein Dutzend anderer Turnerinnen
warf der Chemnitzer
Cheftrainerin Gabriele Frehse vor,
sie gemobbt und trotz Verletzungen
zum Training gezwungen zu haben.
Ruby und Naomi van Dijk sagen,
dass Schmerzmittel und Injektionen
ohne Rezept frei verteilt wurden
– und ohne das Wissen der Eltern.
Aber die Zwillinge hatten wegen
ihrer Vorgeschichte das Gefühl,
nichts dagegen sagen zu können.
Weil halt es immer hieß: „Ihr seid so lästig!“
und „Ihr seid das Problem!“, hieß es dann …
Also wollten wir einfach nicht lästig sein.
Also, wir wollten einfach zeigen,
dass wir eben eigentlich fleißig sind und dass
wir selber turnen … gerne turnen möchten,
und haben auch deswegen auch viele
Sachen gar nicht erst angesprochen.
Das hatte seinen Preis.
Ruby van Dijk musste ihre ständigen
Rückenschmerzen ignorieren.
Eine Trainerin sagte ihr, das seien nur
die Nerven vor dem Wettkampf.
Dann gab’s noch eine Nebentrainerin in
Chemnitz und die hat mir eben häufig gesagt,
das wäre Einbildung, die Rückenschmerzen,
und ob ich den Unterschied
zwischen Muskelkater und richtigen
Schmerzen überhaupt kennen würde.
Und das ging eben anderthalb Jahre lang so.
Und dann habe ich das irgendwann auch
geglaubt, dass es natürlich nur Einbildung ist.
Aber es war nicht nur Einbildung:
Ruby, der der Zugang zu ihren
MRT-Bildern verwehrt wurde,
brauchte schließlich eine Operation.
Trainerin Frehse, die während der Prüfung
der Vorwürfe suspendiert ist,
hat alle Anschuldigungen als
„haltlos“ bezeichnet und sagt,
dass sie nie Grenzen überschritten habe.
Dieses klare Dementi hat die Zwillinge dazu
veranlasst, ihre Geschichte zu erzählen.
Aber wir können auf jeden Fall bestätigen,
dass es nicht haltlose Vorwürfe sind,
die die Mädchen vorgebracht haben.
Also, zwei, drei von den Mädchen waren ja
auch gleichzeitig mit uns damals in Chemnitz.
Und da waren wir ja quasi
Zeugen dann dabei,
wie die anderen dann schlecht
behandelt wurden zum Beispiel.
Und da können wir einfach sagen,
dass es nicht haltlos war.
Aktuell treten Ruby und Naomi
van Dijk nur national an
und träumen nicht mehr
vom internationalen Erfolg.
Aber zumindest können sie jetzt wieder mit
einem Lächeln auf dem Gesicht turnen.